Every week, dozens of new manga chapters arrive
to entertain all of us consumers
Ju Jutsu Kaisen, My Hero, One Piece, Hajime no Ippo
I can go onand on about the manga that I fervently waitfor, be it weekly or monthly
But something thatoften goes forgotten is what goes on behindthat awaited weekly release
The blood, sweat,and tears that manga authors–or mangakas–
put into creating a mere 20 pages. But what is just20 pages, a couple minutes out of our day forus readers,
is a week of non-stop work, little
sleep, malnutrition, and stress for the author
anime like Bakuman have shed light on
the life of a mangaka in a very realistic
way and the sad truth is that being a manga
writer is essentially voluntary enslavement
Meeting deadlines, living up to fan expectations,company expectations, and their own expectationsas writers thinking up a plot
Today I willgo into the sad and dark reality of being a
manga author and the extreme toll it's
taken on countless authors to this day
After getting picked up by a big publishing
company like Shonen Jump, though you would
expect it to get easier from there, this is far
from the truth for mangakas. There are no breaks
The weekly schedule for most mangakas relies on
less than six hours of sleep every day
A numberthat reduces usually the bigger and more popular
the manga is
Eichiro Oda (yes ik it's the wrong picture lol)
the author of One Piece and the biggest manga in the history of the world,
is reported to on average sleep only 3 hours from2am to 5am
Another source claims that these three
hours actually consist of only 30-minute napsevery four hours
So, why is time so limited?
Well, you have to imagine creating a short story from
start to finish all within one week and all of the
processes involved
After turning in the previousweek's chapter on sunday, the cycle begins anew.Immediately.
According to an anonymous mangaka'sschedule, from noon on Sunday to 5am on Tuesdayit consists almost entirely of storyboarding
Deciding on panels, what characters appear in each,the story of the chapter, how it ends
Essentially planing out its entire structure. The only breakin that long period of time is two hours for sleep
and one hour for breakfast – that is as long as
you consider meetings with their editors as
still work of course. And you can tell from
the rest of the week just how packed it is
coloring the panels, shading, working on the finalmanuscript, only three hours of free time exist in
the entire week excluding eating and sleeping
which are the bare necessities
But again, toreturn to the idea of voluntary enslavement thatI mentioned earlier–because it does seem ratherharsh–
we have to remember that it is voluntary.
Mangakas, despite the terrible schedule, do thisall for a reason
Yoshiro Togashi, the author
of Hunter x Hunter, which is notorious for taking
long periods of hiatus, stated that, "It has come to
the point where either the story concludes first
or I die before that happens. But... I do intend
to finish it" that end game looks rather bleak
considering Hunter x Hunter's current hiatus chart
lines with primarily breaks for the past years
but we can never underestimate the passionof a mangaka
Likewise, Oda told his currenteditor when he first joined to, "Die for One Piece"
Mangakas are extremely dedicated to their craft
Of course sleep deprivation isn't the
only cost of being a mangaka either
Sitting in a chair for so long working on mangaleads to numerous health hazards, they can develop
diabetes, despite almost all mangakas being veryskinny and almost frail
Tendinitis can develop intheir hands from drawing so long
Somethingthat is so common amongst mangakas that it
isn't even an expectation that they'll get it
they just accept it as a way of life
One of the members of Clamp, a female mangaka collective
who created Card Captor Sakura among other names,
suffered from lumbar compression fracture in
2011 because she spent too many hours hunched
over her chair and straining her back drawing
Tagashi, the author of Hunter x Hunter also deals
with aggravated back pain that prevents him
from consistently putting out chapters
Otherseries like Vagabond and Berserk, despite being
some of the most highly rated manga of all time
also suffered an early fate due to health concerns
of the authors
This culture of overworkingyourself isn't exclusive to mangakas however,
as the concept of Karoshi, "Death by Overwork"
is very prevalent across all of japan. In 2016,
it was estimated that one in five workerswere at risk of Karoshi
This is so serious of an
issue in the country in fact, that the government
passed a reform bill in 2018 that limited
overtime and fined violators for overworking
Japan is a very collectivism-oriented country,
prioritizing their group's success over individual
Kona Shiomachi made an illustration in response
to the 2015 death of an employee due to Karoshi
the key line being, "If I move one step further
in front of the train, I wouldn't have to go towork tomorrow"
The idea of Karoshi is reflected
in people dedicating themselves to their work
and employers. To an extent that is often not
just prioritizing group success over individual
but it comes at the cost of individual health
as well, be it physical or just mental well-being
Kishimoto Masashi the creator of Naruto, while
the series was still being serialized never had
the time to take his wife on a honeymoon despite
being married for 15 years
Tite Kubo, the author ofBleach, once spoke in an interview at San DiegoComic-Con on how his appearance at Comic-Con
was far from a vacation, as he had to draw anychapters he missed before he went on the trip
Which considering the anonymous typical schedule
for our mangaka that we looked at earlier
I have no idea how he was able to fit it all in,
just another testament to a mangaka's dedication
And of course these problems exist
on the condition that the mangakadoes make it
Their manga makes it into Shonen
Jump, or another renowned publisher, and they getpopular
Because if they don't get popular
enough then they can't afford assistants, a
valuable asset for any manga writer and have to
do all of the work themselves, filling in lines
backgrounds, shading, all of it on their own. The
pay is also nearly criminal, the assistant to the
writer of Prince of Tennis gave the figure at
about $100 per page, and though
that could mean about $8000 per
month for a weekly author producing 20 pages a
week, this is before taxes and hiring assistants
which will of course detract heavily from it
Though it isn't necessarily terrible, relative
to the insane schedule they have and overwork
it is certainly not comparatively enough, getting
an anime adaptation can also drastically improve
the exposure and popularity of the manga, but then
as we see with one piece for example it is stillfar from easy
Oda (wrong pic again my b) is one of the most hard-working
and overworked by extent mangakas out there
No matter how big your manga, is it
is always rigorous and constant work
And this all continues until your series finishes
whether it is of your own accord or not because
it isn't just as simple as writing a chapter
of one big book, but instead creating a new
story every week that has to attract consistent
attention and remain exciting and interesting
Otherwise if the fans don't like
it, the company is quick to drop you
after all there's no shortage of new manga
coming out in Japan they can always getsomeone else
On the other hand, in anime like
Bakuman we saw how the company pressured the
mangaka to continue the series despite the author
feeling like it reached its natural end already
Sometimes companies will do this because the manga
is so popular that they can't afford to lose it
which means that sometimes even the author of
the series themselves don't have full controlover their own story
However, this isn't a super
common occurrence we see authors like Tite Kubo
who decided himself that he would draw Bleach
to the conclusion he wanted despite health
concerns and critiques from the editors, which
is again another reminder that this "enslavement"
is still voluntary at the end of the day
Whenyou look at everything put together, it's a rather
unavoidable problem. Be it due to collectivist
cultural standards, Karoshi, meeting deadlines
or just the mangaka's own desire to finish what
they started, the process of creating manga is
difficult to say the least. We can only hope as
readers that the reward they get from working
creating something that resonates with us fans
and succeeds is enough for them
Manga is truly thelife work of anyone creating it, and so we do have
to be grateful for everything they've done forus
What do you guys think of all
this? Leave a comment down below
As always, this has been the Anime Culture
Corner. I hope you enjoyed the video
don't forget to like and subscribe for future
in-depth show manga and character analyses